Das ist wirklich mehr als krass: Die hawaiische
Insel namens “East Island” ist tatsächlich
komplett vom Ozean verschlungen worden.
Und das fast über Nacht.
Das macht selbst Forschungsteams fassungslos.
Und sie ist ist bereits die zweite Insel in
dieser Region, die komplett überschwemmt
wurde.
Wie das passieren konnte und welche fatalen
Folgen das mit sich bringt jetzt in Clixoom
Science & Fiction Hier gibt es faszinierende
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, denn nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Konkret geht es um die hawaiische Insel “East
Island” im pazifischen Ozean.
Sie gehört zu den French Frigate Shoals - vom
Durchmesser her das größte Atoll der Nordwestlichen
Hawaii-Inseln.
Doch Anfang Oktober passierte es und “East
Island” war quasi über Nacht verschwunden.
Damals wütete der Hurrikan namens “Walaka”
im Pazifik.
Er wird mit zu den stärksten tropischen Stürmen
seit Beginn der Aufzeichnungen gezählt.
Mit einer Geschwindigkeit von bis zu 260 Kilometer
pro Stunde fegte er über die Region.
Und auch wenn er glücklicherweise nicht auf
Land traf, das von Menschen bewohnt wurde,
sind die Folgen verheerend.
4,5 Hektar groß war East Island ursprünglich
und somit die zweitgrößte Insel der French
Frigate Shoals.
Der Klimaforscher Charles Fletcher war noch
im Juli auf der jetzt verschluckten Insel.
Schon länger war seinem Forschungsteam klar,
dass East Island irgendwann einmal untergehen
würde, doch die Fachleute gaben der Insel
dafür noch einige Jahrzehnte.
East Island ist nicht die erste Insel, die
im Ozean verschwunden ist: Auch “Trig Island”
wurde bereits vom Wasser überschwemmt, doch
dies dauerte mehrere Jahre.
Zudem sind die Fachleute auch äußerst überrascht,
wie schnell die East Island im Ozean versunken
ist.
Ihr könnt es Euch vielleicht schon denken:
Wahrscheinlich liegt es am Klimawandel, dass
die Hurrikans immer heftiger und intensiver
werden - darüber hatten wir schon einmal
ausführlich bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
berichtet.
In einem Interview sagt Fletcher: “Ich hatte
einen Heilige-Scheiße-Moment und dachte ‘Oh
mein Gott, sie ist weg’.
Das macht die Vielfalt des Ökosystems dieses
Planeten wieder ein Stück weit instabiler”.
Und tatsächlich: Die Insel hatte beispielsweise
für die Grüne Meeresschildkröte eine wirklich
existentielle Bedeutung.
Sie diente als zentraler Nistplatz - und zwar
sage und schreibe für die Hälfte der weltweiten
Population.
Das ist wirklich tragisch, vor allem, wenn
man bedenkt, dass die Grüne Meeresschildkröte
vom Aussterben bedroht ist.
Bestätigt auch der Biologe Charles Littnan:
“Es besteht kein Zweifel, dass dies die
wichtigste Insel zum Nisten der Meeresschildkröten
war”.
Und auch für die Hawaii-Mönchsrobbe ist
der Untergang der Insel fatal, denn alleine
eine Siebtel der weltweiten Population wurde
auf “East Island” geboren.
Fest steht also: Beiden Tierarten fehlt durch
den Untergang der Insel jetzt ein zentraler
Lebensraum.
Forschungsteams können nur in einem kleinen
Punkt Entwarnung geben: Denn die Tiere waren
von dem Wirbelsturm wohl nicht direkt betroffen,
sondern waren zu diesem Zeitpunkt bereits
weitergezogen.
Was der Untergang der Insel langfristig für
die Region und die Arten dort bedeutet, steht
noch nicht fest.
Das können die Experten und Expertinnen wohl
erst bei der nächsten Sommer-Expedition untersuchen.
Nicht ausgeschlossen ist es auch, dass “East
Island” irgendwann wieder auftaucht.
Fest steht aber, dass selbst in einem solchen
Fall die Landschaft oberhalb des Wasserspiegels
lange brauchen wird, um sich von ihrem Schicksal
zu erholen.
Wenn ihr kein Video zu diesen und allen anderen
themen in Zukunft verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Exciting Discovery:
Ice Age in Europe - Will the Gulf Stream come
to a standstill?
Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!